these are hoping that the addition of
starling marte can kind of put a boost
to this offense which at times this year
has been a little bit sluggish and
tonight he's going to be batting second
he's going to be playing center field
which is very interesting and taking aim
at a team that he pitched well against
last year is dylan bundy one and two the
count to mark hannah 259 11 home runs 36
runs battery
and it hit him
so here's starling martay his first at
bat as a member of the athletics
great shot inside with canna running and
marte's first at-bat with the athletics
is a walk
runner's not going and the pitch is up
and away
so a hit batter two walks and the a's
have the bases loaded lowry a 386
batting average with runners in scoring
position
first pitch is bounced diving play
that's fletcher fletcher is going to
throw to first to get the out there
cannon does come in to score
nice play by fletcher
here's lauriano's batting 245 with 14
homers 37 driven in
laureano first pitch drives one toward
the left field corner martay scores
olson's going to trot in to score
laureano in the second with a double so
ramon lauriano on the first pitch he
sees smacks a double into the left field
corner and the a's lead three nothing
frankie montage tonight one of my
favorites to watch blazing fastball
anywhere from 95 to 100 miles an hour
devastating split finger and nasty
slider
another 3-2 that's a good pitch strike
three on the outside corner ohtani
didn't like it but it was a very good
pitch
when we get back
ramon l'oreal settles underneath it and
that'll do it nice three-up three-down
inning for frankie montos
3-2
ah love it
shift is on
stasi shoots it against the shift
and has a one out single here in the
fourth
good pitch that is a good pitch so
marsh
strikes out and that is
strikeout number four
oh two
off the end of the bat nicely done
iglesias guides it into center field
he is so good on
breaking pitches
and he got it here's the splitter well
he stayed with it through three straight
splitters to adam eaton gets the
strikeout
knocked down mayfield is not going to be
able to pick it up clean and that's
going to be in there
in the dirt andrews running throws
gorgeous
[Applause]
that pitch nowhere close so kenna walks
hits it up the middle and that's gonna
get through into center field for a base
hit i'll take that too so the shift was
on they had
three infielders on the left side but
that ball was hit pretty hard
jose quintana continues to warm up
runners go on 3-2 swinging to miss throw
down mayfield's tag safe
to two
got him
those three runs in the first by oakland
still the only ones in the game
[Music]
down low
and ohtani walks to bring up goslin
waiting for the home run ball is not as
easy to do and here he goes he's running
murphy's throw not in time
15 stolen base of the year for autonomy
chapman's got it it's a fair ball to
throw across and olson digs it out and
chapman once again saves the a's and
saves the run on a dazzling playback a
third on a well-hit ball by gosselin
winding up in foul territory and no time
to set himself
[Applause]
quintana
it's good to see the strikeout pitch has
been there for him tonight
[Applause]
that's a swing
more than portland's gonna be
even in more of a sour mood after that
62 strikeouts and 45 and a third add one
he has struck out five straight every
man he's faced three-nothing oakland
basketball and he got the call on the
outside corner up and drops his back
right patch right there that's a
fastball strike three called on the
outside corner
and here it is and it's swung out of
miss a fastball away and montas strikes
out the side blazing his way through the
bottom of the sixth at the big a and
after six is still three nothing
athletics
so far those three runs have held up
murphy got a first pitch
like maybe a slider and he slaps it in
the right field for a base hit
check swing little tapper charging
iglesias oh goodness
i don't believe that
[Applause]
i've seen guys flip it with their glove
especially behind the bag but when
you're running away from the bag that's
amazing
up the middle that's a base in elvis
anders makes the turn he's going to try
for third and marsha's throw is
cut off two on two out three nothing a's
in the seventh
oh that one is thrown away
and the a's are gonna get a run as elvis
anders trots in to score
and that's another error for the angels
here it comes
look at it hit him try to run it inside
again and ricochet it off of the body of
olson and he'll be awarded first base
breaking ball in the dirt and lowry
walks
jam shot
nice play look at austin warren like a
big leaguer nice job
base is loaded no problem
[Applause]
swing and a miss and there's the
splitter 88 miles an hour eaton struck
out on a splitter in the fourth hitting
he was not happy with himself and the o2
swing and i missed another split and the
inning is over one two three
and double digits and strikeouts for
frankie motas for the second consecutive
game romo has been great he has not
allowed a run in his last 11 games
3-1
it's out
three walks for ohtani tonight
and that was one that i got away with
right there
martay
grabs it that'll do it so a walk nothing
else ninth inning coming up
lou trevino out of the stretch delivers
here's the pitch breaky ball swung out
of miss this game is over as the as
notched their ninth shutout
of this 20-21 campaign